Imagine knowing that there’s a monster,
right under your nose.
Imagine knowing that this monster is capable
of killing any human being on earth, and all
because they simply saw a photograph of its
face.
When this monster is on the warpath, literally
nothing can stop it.
No weapon that human beings have invented
is capable of even slowing it down.
Imagine knowing, in the age of mass media,
of clicks and shares, of 24 hour news, smart
phones, and limitless social media connecting
billions across the globe, that one stray
picture of this monster leaked in the wrong
place could cause the end of the world as
we know it.
And this fateful, terrifying day could come
at any time.
Congratulations, you now know how it feels
to be Dr. Dan, the hot-headed lead SCP Foundation
researcher on the SCP-096 case.
The anomaly itself requires no real introduction
- the infamous, mass-murdering Shy Guy has
haunted the nightmares of Foundation experts
for years.
But nobody is more haunted by this thing than
Dr. Dan himself.
For over a decade now, he has firmly believed
that there’s one solution to the 096 problem:
Termination, with extreme prejudice.
In his eyes, to think that 096 is ever truly
contained is an illusion.
They could never be sure of how many pictures
of it are out there, floating around just
waiting to be seen, like a time bomb waiting
to go off.
The resources spent containing it and cleaning
up after its rampages, he would often argue,
would be better spent instead figuring out
how to finally kill it.
But seeing as we’re talking about the SCP
Foundation here, not the Global Occult Coalition,
the O5 Council didn’t see it quite the same
way.
They constantly overturned Dr. Dan’s termination
requests, leaving the paranoid researcher
more furious with each rejection.
He tried to warn them, again and again and
again.
“Don’t you see?
It’s like a stick of dynamite, and the fuse
is already lit.
If you don’t let me put it out before it’s
too late, there won’t even be anyone left
to pick up the pieces!”
But his pleas fell on deaf ears.
Until, of course, Incident 096-1-a, a dark
and bloody day still looked back on with shame
and horror by even the most hardened members
of Foundation staff.
It was the day that SCP-096 gave everyone
a taste of the mass carnage it was truly capable
of.
Dr. Dan wasn’t even there when containment
was first breached.
He was off on an expedition in the snowy mountains
where 096 was first found, trying to discover
clues to its true origin.
Dr. Dan’s second in command, Dr. Oleksei,
was also lucky enough to be outside of the
containment area when the Shy Guy escaped.
According to interviews he gave at debriefing
tribunals, he was in the break room, treating
himself to a warm cup of joe.
All the other personnel assigned to 096’s
containment and research were near its containment
chamber, a giant cube made of reinforced metal,
observing a live feed of data being collected
from the cube’s interior.
As usual, sensors indicated that 096 was pacing
within.
For obvious reasons, the Foundation doesn’t
maintain any kind of live visual surveillance
on 096.
It wouldn’t be worth the risk.
But what seemed like an otherwise quiet day
suddenly took a turn for the insane.
The monitors began displaying terrifying data,
indicating an imminent containment breach,
as the wails of the creature within the cube
echoed out through its metal walls.
Some tried to run.
Others did all they could to engage emergency
procedures, while guards armed with heavy
weaponry rushed into the room.
They all knew in their hearts that it wouldn’t
save them, but what else could they do?
A huge dent bulged out from the side of the
cube, then another, before the metal was torn
open like tissue paper as the furious hands
of the Shy Guy began clawing their way through
it.
Secondary layers of protection were deployed,
but they didn’t help, 096 just kept ripping
through all the barriers.
As everyone in attendance knew: Once it was
in its rage state, nothing could stop it.
Literally nothing.`
The guards attempted to fire on the anomaly,
but their bullets did no good.
As the creature burst free, most of the people
in the room had at least momentary visual
contact with its face.
In response, Code Lima was declared, and the
entire chamber was flooded with a fast-acting
nerve gas, killing everyone.
Everyone except for 096 itself of course.
Within two minutes, 096 had broken free of
the entire containment site, and began running
through the desert at breakneck speeds towards
its distant target.
The Foundation needed to act fast and find
a way to stop it before it hit a population
center where the death toll would skyrocket.
Team Echo Romeo were dispatched to pursue
the creature in a heavily-armed attack helicopter
while MTF Tau-1, a task force specializing
in SCP-096 containment and recovery, forged
ahead to identify the anomaly’s target,
designated 096-1, and to move any other civilians
out of harm’s way.
Dr. Dan was alerted of the disastrous situation
and offered guidance to both teams from afar.
Echo Romeo’s chopper pursued 096, barely
able to keep up.
Dr. Dan recommended attempting to at least
slow the creature down with heavy arms fire,
even though he knew actually stopping it would
be impossible.
A member of the team used a modified XM500
anti-materiel rifle to fire several rounds
at the creature, but even the shot that passed
directly through its head appeared to have
no effect on it.
But at least they had a lock on its direction
now.
096 always travels in a straight line, directly
towards its target, smashing through any obstacles
in its way.
This means its intended direction is relatively
easy to track, and people in the path of its
trajectory are even easier to save - but it’s
a high-pressure job reserved for MTF Tau-1.
Tau-1 passed over Echo Romeo and 096 in a
series of eight v-22 Ospreys, hoping beyond
hope that they could outrun the creature;
since there were several different towns in
its direct path.
But, thanks once again to the one and only
Dr. Dan, Echo Romeo and Tau-1 had a secret
weapon that neither team had ever possessed
before: SCRAMBLE.
SCRAMBLE was an advanced computer program,
created by Dr. Dan with the help of Dr. Oleksei,
which was coded into microprocessors for modification
into camera feeds and viewing goggles.
The program had been fed intricate data concerning
every single detail of 096’s face, and as
the name suggests, when encountering that
visual data in real life it scrambles it beyond
recognition.
In theory, it would make it far safer for
operatives to be around SCP-096 without activating
its rage state.
In theory.
It wasn’t long before disaster struck.
096 had made its way onto I-40, and had begun
attacking vehicles it encountered, killing
the people inside.
By this point, it had already outrun the Echo
Romeo chopper, rendering them essentially
useless.
Tau-1 just had to forge ahead along 096’s
trajectory, and try to get as many people
out of the danger zone as possible until 096-1
was located and destroyed by the anomaly.
Years of training for an awful day like this
had paid off, as the first three towns along
096’s path were successfully evacuated.
The Shy Guy just ran right through all of
them, and no lives were lost.
The same, however, could not be said for town
number four.
As was standard procedure, Tau-1 had everyone
in town gathered up and blindfolded.
The entire team in attendance had modified
night vision goggles with SCRAMBLE microprocessors,
so in theory, they were better off than most
from 096 if things went south.
The Tau-1 members tried in vain to keep everybody
in line.
They were threatening to shoot anyone who
dared to remove their blindfold when 096 finally
appeared.
It tripped during its approach, rolling and
shattering through several houses.
Chaos erupted.
Some people instinctively removed their blindfolds
to see what was going on, and panicked members
of Tau-1 began firing into the crowd.
The screams of the civilians and the bursts
of gunfire were all drowned out by the horrific
wailing of 096 itself as it tore through everyone
and everything to kill the unfortunate souls
who had seen its face.
And given how many had removed their blindfolds
during the initial pandemonium, SCP-096 had
a huge number of the townspeople on its list.
096 located and grabbed the original 096-1,
the person that’d first glimpsed its face
and caused all this, but in the grand scheme
of things, he was just one more body on the
pile that day.
Though of course, we mean this in a purely
metaphorical sense - 096 never leaves entire
bodies.
The Foundation operatives in attendance were
able to figure out what had caused all this
madness and death.
096-1 had been an amateur mountaineer, and
spent his vacations hiking around any mountain
ranges he could gain access to - including
the mountain range that 096 had been inhabiting
prior to its initial capture and containment.
But he hadn’t actually seen 096 on that
fateful trip, which he had taken over a decade
ago.
But in a photograph taken that day of himself,
standing on a picturesque mountainside, 096
made a cameo.
It took up all of four pixels, a tiny off-white
dot against the snow on the back-right side
of the photograph.
This photograph, with all the deadly potency
of an atom bomb, had been sitting there for
years.
Waiting.
When the mountaineer was looking through old
photos that morning and his eyes passed over
those few blurry pixels, he didn’t have
any idea that he had just laid his eyes on
one of the most dangerous anomalies the world
has ever seen.
But you don’t have to know.
Only 096 does.
As Tau-1, led by their commander, Major Jack
Wilford, tried to retake control of the situation,
things got even worse.
It turned out, Dr. Dan’s SCRAMBLE technology
- the one thing that was supposed to have
given them an edge in this situation - didn’t
actually work.
As soon as goggle wearing members of the team
laid eyes on 096, it entered its rage state
and started massacring them.
It tore many of the Mobile Task Force members
to shreds, including a number of the operatives
required for piloting the eight Ospreys.
It was a disaster of truly epic proportions,
and the catastrophic failure of Dr. Dan’s
SCRAMBLE technology was a key factor.
The root of the technology’s failure was
easy enough to figure out.
Dr. Dan’s SCRAMBLE microprocessors worked
fast, but not fast enough.
Fractions-of-a-second glimpses of 096’s
face managed to get through, and that was
more than enough to set 096 off.
Echo Romeo and MTF Epsilon arrived shortly
afterwards to clean up the mess.
It’d been a disaster of such magnitude that
even a CNN reporter arrived on the scene and
started filming before being promptly shut
down by Epsilon.
It was a member of Echo Romeo that finally
slipped the bag over a docile 096’s head,
preparing it for containment once again, the
creature now content that it had eliminated
all of the unfortunate souls who had seen
its face.
He’d found 096 sitting next to a minivan
that had its roof ripped off, the young family
inside being the last to have seen its face.
Things were so awful in the aftermath of the
containment breach that the O5 Council changed
their tune, finally granting Dr. Dan permission
to terminate 096, by any means necessary.
It’s terrifying to think that all this can
unfold because of a couple of poorly-timed
accidents.
But it’s probably even more terrifying to
consider that it wasn’t an accident at all.
It had seemed awfully convenient that both
Dr. Dan and Dr. Oleksei were far from danger
when all hell broke loose.
It was also convenient that, despite the failure
of his technology being a major reason why
the breach was as deadly as it was, Dr. Dan
had still come out of the situation with everything
he wanted.
The Foundation also found this strange, and
the more they looked into it, the more they
found details that didn’t add up.
Alibis began to fall apart.
Coincidences didn’t seem so coincidental,
and eventually a weak link in the chain was
identified - Dr. Oleksei.
Under pressure from the Foundation, Oleksei
spilled everything.
Dr. Dan had essentially orchestrated the entire
containment breach, and on top of that, he
did everything he could to make it as deadly
as possible.
All with the purpose of getting the O5 Council
to see things his way, and finally give him
the permission he needed to devote all of
the SCP-096 resources to its termination.
But it came at a terrible price to Dr. Dan
personally.
For his crimes against the Foundation and
humanity, he was permitted to try and figure
out a way to terminate 096 once and for all,
but as payment for his crimes, he himself
would also be terminated as soon as his task
was complete.
Were the lives of all of those innocent people,
and Dr. Dan’s himself, worth the price of
finally being authorized to terminate SCP-096?
When asked why he did all this, Dr. Dan simply
said…
“It worked.
There was only a matter of time until that
happened in a major population center, and
its face spread over the world news.
I can kill 096, but I’ve killed myself in
the process.”
While we don’t agree with his methods, there’s
something almost admirable about a person
so single mindedly devoted to their cause.
Now check out “SCP-096 - The Shy Guy”
and “SCP-096 - Look at a Picture of the
Shy Guy In Space?
The Shy Guy Questions and Theories” if you’re
still itching for another 096 fix!